you really went on a seven hour seven
week seven month hike
he's been fake this whole time this is
my first time meeting I've been doing
this podcast with the [__] AI version
to him this is my first time meeting
Cody yeah it was a four day hike
backpacked so I like we camped the whole
time and uh the last day
the dude so it was me my parents and my
parents friend who's 59 he was the one
that like he's like an avid Backpacker
he planned the whole thing and uh I
don't like to do prep as the age because
it why it makes me think something bad's
gonna happen it did age-wise right it
did continue so we did we did like 50 to
60 miles in four days so super intense
so basically eight or nine hours on the
trail every day and then we'd Camp wake
up the next morning at 5 30 and start
hiking again the whole time we made it
the whole way
we were three miles from the trailhead
on the last day
to where we had to get the car
there was one last there's a lot of snow
this year because of like all the you
know rainfall and snowfall here so there
was like a lot of snow left on the
mountain and there was a really steep
it's like snow bluff basically that we
had to cross
and I I crossed first and I turned
around and I filmed him because I wanted
to like
because you knew that yeah
no I was like filming [__] like you know
for a vlog or whatever then I put my
phone down
and I watched him because he had about
two steps left on this snow bluff
and so like it basically went like
it was like a huge steep ramp full of
snow and then like the trail started
right here and it was just rocks right
here but a little bit of snow left on
the trail
I watched him slip
try to get his footing
and then he starts to fall over his pack
takes him over because we're wearing
like 35 pound backpacks and he just
hits his head on a rock
lands at the bottom basically rocks like
stopped his fall
and he's like he just kind of like sits
up and I'm like did I just like watch
this dude die did I just record it
yo
no it wasn't like 3x Zoom damn yeah
two minutes yo you good
yeah dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo the sports [__]
down there holy [__] bro do you ever see
like you ever like watch a car accident
or something like that and all you can
do is just stand there and be like Oh
yeah this is getting worse and worse
it's not like that it was just like I
didn't know what to do I just like
watched this happen right in front of me
and then we just like let them sit there
for a second and then I don't know
basically he like severely dislocated
his shoulder so when he went down there
and he's bleeding from the head and you
could see his shoulder socket like
poking out of his arm
and he's like I can't he and we don't
we're not sure like is he concussed he
hit his head so hard that we're like
just make sure he's good but we're in
the [__] mountains there's no service
yeah so we had to set off an SOS on like
the our like emergency response system
anyways fast forward three hours he had
to get airlifted out of there wow and
the helicopter Comes This is meanwhile
he's going in and out of shock the whole
time so we're like wrapping you know
sleeping bags around him making sure
he's like warm because he's like
shivering going in and out of shock
like writhing in pain yeah and uh
finally the helicopter arrives after
like three hours of waiting and they're
just circling and we're like why the
[__] aren't they like I thought they'd
like lower down a thing pick them up you
know you see like videos of that [__]
happening yeah sorry hook your backpacks
[Laughter]
the little [__] game monkeys in a
barrel like you're all just like one arm
the shoulder's already off
sorry that's [__] up so the helicopter
is spinning yeah yeah okay so but okay
he's good just like Fast Forward okay
he's fine everything ended up being fine
so like I feel fine joking about it but
he's not good yeah yeah
now he's actually
left his ass there yeah uh the
helicopter is like circling and we're
like this dude's like in a lot of pain
he's like just get him to the hospital
yeah and we're watching the helicopter
just like go back and forth like what
the [__] are they doing they keep like
throwing out these yellow bits of like
fabric I guess to like read the air
because we were in this like little
canyon oh so they were doing like Recon
trying to figure out like if they could
land where they could land how much how
heavy like if they had to go dump fuel
oh and then the sheriff we get a text
from the sheriff and he's like
they might leave to get gas
if they leave don't freak out they're
definitely gonna be back wow and we're
like [__] how do we tell him this he's
like sitting there like just thinking
that he's like minutes away from being
saved basically you guys gotta keep
making helicopter sounds
dry as [__] yeah where's this guy
[Laughter]
oh
they had to go dump fuel come back they
landed they had 20 minutes of idle time
so we had to like pick them up and get
him down the mountain across this like
Marsh and then up another field of
Boulders basically to get him into the
helicopter we got him there with five
minutes to spare wow like it felt like a
[__] movie yeah because this
Monster's a chopper we got him there
what are you in German yeah
imagine
[Laughter]
this bro imagine
foreign
[Laughter]
vertigo
this this quote is crazy
there you go slow that down after this
guy's just spun around like wild there
you go yeah ah there you go slow down
yeah he's doing nothing right but you
guys don't hikes nah man never camped I
want to go upward Hill man crazy Hills
and [__] oh no camp now I never slept
outside never been in a tent yeah I'm
really afraid of bears like what do I do
oh I mean yeah we saw the picture
you're taller than a bear what the [__]
remember that
it's like the video remember it's like
the it's like audio of this guy getting
attacked by a bear oh yeah and it's just
it's just scarring yeah this is a brown
bear I think this was a Grizzly yeah he
got like destroyed like he got like torn
apart by this bear and you just hear him
scream
is